New York gubernatorial candidate and
former Sex in the City star Cynthia next
Nixon put that fight in the headlines
this week before last night's debate
against Governor Andrew Cuomo Nixon's
team asked the temperature in the Hall
be raised to 76 degrees balmy according
to a calling to cold work environments
notoriously sexist
Nicki batiste is here with what women
men and science have to say about it
Nicki good morning we're matching good
morning we are matching this is a hot
topic Governor Cuomo's office told CBS
News in a statement he has more
important things to focus on than room
temperature but we found Cynthia Nixon
is not alone in wanting a warmer room
the battle over the thermostat seems to
be raging in offices across the country
my opponent lives in the world of
fiction I live in the world of fat there
was a chill in this debate Hall
Wednesday night and have a whole
difference not from the icy exchanges
between actors turns were notorious
Cynthia Nixon and New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo but from the actual
temperature Cynthia Nixon team says
office temperatures are notoriously
sexist they requested this debate all be
warm to 76 degrees but it's only 69 in
here and I have got the goosebumps to
prove it why is it that time again women
have to be the ones who are freezing
cold at work Nixon senior adviser
Rebecca Katz said Governor Cuomo is
known for preferring brisk temperatures
and Nixon's office unsuccessfully tried
to raise the temp Nixon's request heated
social media Wednesday night with women
and men sharing their often polar
opposite office temperature preferences
I keep two jackets here at the Herald
public relations firm in New York City
we also found an office divided by the
thermostat you have summer on one side
and winter on the other side while some
men use desk vans and sported short
sleeves we found some women bundled up
and using space heaters women should
know that they're not crazy it's not all
in their head CBS News medical
contributor dr. Tara Narula
says there is a science behind why women
feel colder it has to do with
thermoregulation
and metabolic rate and clothing
differences a 2015 study found that most
office temperatures are set using a
1960s formula that relies on the
metabolic rate of an average man dr.
Narula says men tend to be comfortable
with a temperature in the low 70s and
women in the mid to high 70s finding a
point in the middle where both men and
women can be happy would be the ideal
situation but for the New York
politicians at at Herald PR that may be
easier said than done I think I'd be
okay with high 60s more or less just so
we can hit it kind of immediate I'd say
we can compromise at a low 73 we have
our own thermostat battles here at CBS
News so we decided to take a look at
what the temperature really is here in
our studio and according to this you
guys it's 73 degrees I don't know it
feels colder than that
that's nice actually it usually is
pretty cold here but thank you John you
always agree when Gil and I say it's
cold that we should turn up the heat so
we appreciate that well thank you for
noticing control room has ever I feel
like I'm warmed by the glow of original
report I'm always in a fleece in a
blanket when I'm not on set always here
I prefer a first stall just wrap it
around
I do think Governor Cuomo has to be
careful about how he responds to that by
saying I have more important things to
do to talk about office temperature it
can come off as very dismissive you have
to work with other people and other
people have different feelings and you
have to always take those into account
right and if you're freezing you can't
perform at your best so yeah thank you
Nikki okay it's all of that thanks Nikki